quite a few of you guys have been asking
us to make a video on the real
differences between the iPhone 11 and
the 11pro so here it is as well as the
question of which of these premium
iPhones you should buy the answer
actually boils down to something very
simple I'll explain in just a bit if
you're a fan of colors you get a lot
more options on the iPhone 11 while the
11pro is a bit more limited but the new
midnight green color is much nicer than
I expected on the back they get a new
unique square bump that's machined out
of a single sheet of glass with the 11
getting two circular camera bumps while
the 11 Pro gets a nicely arranged three
bumps that in my opinion scream premium
more on those cameras in just a minute
the matte glass back looks really nice
on the 11pro while the 11 gets a glossy
back with matte on the square bump I
personally love the smooth finish on the
11 pro's matte glass which is also very
fingerprint and micro scotch resistant
but others may not like how slippery it
is and they may prefer the iPhone 11 for
the extra grip in the hand the 11pro
also has a glossy stainless steel frame
which feels very grippy and premium but
it's more susceptible to micro scratches
while the regular 11 has an aluminum
frame that Apple has been using since
the iPhone 6 but if you like to use a
case with your iPhone the difference in
feel won't matter with last year's
iPhones the 10r was noticeably thicker
than the 10s but this year the 11pro got
a bit thicker so you won't really notice
a big difference in your hand like you
did last year the 11pro comes in two
sizes five-point eight inches which I
personally feel is too small and 6.5
inches which is nice for the large
display but a bit uncomfortable to hold
in your hand so in my opinion the 6.1
inch size of the iPhone 11 is actually
the perfect middle ground offering a
large display while feeling perfect in
the hand the iPhone 11 features the
exact same LCD display from last year's
10r with less than 1080p resolution
which is a bummer but you can't really
tell with regular use unless you pixel
peep or watch a very high quality video
it's got the same true tone technology
in excellent color accuracy with p-3
wide color gamut the iPhone 11 pros
display has a much higher resolution a
much better contrast ratio thanks to it
being an OLED display and it got even
bright
this year the main difference is that
you can't watch high-quality HDR content
on the regular eleven and you'll have
more trouble seeing the display when
you're outside in broad daylight
the benefit of the iPhone 11 pros OLED
display is that using dark mode or a
darker wallpaper will actually save
battery life because the individual
pixels emit their own light and can
actually turn off completely when
displaying black one of the biggest
downsides with last year's iPhone 10 R
was that it didn't get 3d touch like on
the 10s but this year even the 11 Pro
doesn't get it anymore now the one
display difference that matters the most
to me is that the display bezels on the
11 are noticeably larger than the ones
on the 11 Pro which already seem large
compared to other phones like the note
10 plus so with all the visible
differences out of the way let's get
into feature differences something new
this year is that the iPhone 11 Pro
actually comes with an 18 watt fast
charger in the box instead of the super
old and slow 5 watt charger with the
iPhone 11
now if the slow 5 watt charger is
keeping you from buying the 11 it
shouldn't it actually supports the same
exact fast charging speed as the 11 Pro
you just have to buy the fast charger
separately which unfortunately is about
$30 from Apple thankfully you can buy a
charger with the same exact 18 watts of
fast charging speed for only $16 right
now on Amazon we'll drop a link down in
the description below now if I could
explain the iPhone 11 pro and the pro
Macs in just two words they would be
battery life my 11 pro max is the first
phone I've ever had where I can do
literally anything on my phone and no
longer have to even think about battery
life it's so great that I've actually
stopped checking it throughout the day
now the battery life on the 11 isn't as
good but it's still rated for an extra
hour over the 10 R which already had
better battery life than last year's
iPhone 10s max so it's still pretty
great the iPhone 11 pro also gets better
water resistance lasting 30 minutes in
up to 13 feet of water which is more
than the deepest point of a regular
swimming pool while the 11 lasts the
same 30 minutes in up to 6 and a half
feet of water other than all of that in
a couple of small differences in the
cameras which I'll mention in just a
moment everything else is basically the
same you can the same a 13 Bionic chip
which is the fastest processor on
a smartphone and you even get the same
four gigabytes of RAM whereas last
year's ten are only got three gigabytes
you get the same face ID system the same
hue one location chip the same spatial
audio speakers with Dolby Atmos support
the same Wi-Fi six and gigabit LTE speed
the same dual SIM support in the same
wireless charging speed and now for the
cameras you get the same exact wide in
ultra wide lenses the photos and videos
coming out of these two phones are
literally identical with the same video
recording features the same crazy good
video stabilization night mode second
gen smart HDR and basically every other
feature available on the 11pro however
the one thing the pro has is the
telephoto lens and is good for a couple
of things the first is being able to
zoom in more for photos and videos in
second you can take more realistic
close-up portrait photos if you try a
close-up portrait on the iPhone 11s wide
lens it greatly distorts the shape of
the face so you have to take a step back
snap the photo and then crop into it and
post to get a close-up which can reduce
quality and that's basically the only
difference in the cameras so if you're
still trying to figure out if you should
buy the iPhone 11 or the iPhone 11 Pro
I'll make it really simple for you if
you're coming from a premium smartphone
that packs a high quality OLED display
like the iPhone 10 should proudly go for
the 11 Pro or 11 pro max because you'll
probably notice the lack of contrast on
the iPhone 11s LCD display as well as a
thicker bezels but if you're coming from
an older LCD packing phone with large
top and bottom bezels like the iPhone 6
7 or 8 then you should go with the
iPhone 11 and spend the extra 3 to $400
difference on something else like a
sixteen dollar fast charger by using the
link down below if you enjoy this
comparison make sure it's half that like
button and click the circle about to
subscribe check out some of those videos
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]